there's trying to
rescue the person now
the network is
very muddy, a lot of mud here
[Applause]
here the desperation is quite great here in the
place, several residents here with a bucket
and a hoe trying to remove some more
of this mud and the SAMU is up there,
you go there  above Guilherme it seems
that they found a person
and here on the other side also seems to
find another and you
share our transmission they
are asking for wood here I am asking for
wood here Guilherme [
Music]
my God in heaven
my God in heaven we
keep updating you  there
is already a lot of mud here in the place
of this mud that goes down and the
water doesn't stop going down the water keeps going down
all the time and the
concern starts here again the
rain
and you share our
transmission there and now the  residents vented